Hi there. This is Will Arnett, host of the Will Arnett FunZone podcast.
This week, what?
We've talked about this, man. We've been over this like so many times.
Okay. But we are doing it though, right? We are going to do that.
No, we're not. This is Smartless.
Okay. FunZone.
I know. Well, what are we doing today?
All we need is a super simple, welcome to Smartless.
Oh, right.
You're a dig deep for this.
Welcome to Smartless.
Now listen, Jason, before we get too deep into the show,
we need to talk about the crew caller.
And now you've, tell us what, walk us through what happened this morning.
Well, I went ahead and I got showered and changed prior to our record
for my golf engagement following this record.
Oh, you go.
Yeah, I'm not proud to say, but chuckles over there does it too.
So, yeah, so I put on my collared shirt as you're required to do.
And then it's a little chilly here in Los Angeles.
So I put on a nice wrap over the top of it, a nice cashmere wrap.
And the collar on that creaneck was a little tight.
So it took the collar of my undershirt there and pushed it up.
And then Will was hurting me, calling it a mock turtorn.
So that sweater's gone.
I'm going to go to a V-neck.
And Will said we were talking about money for producing the podcast.
And Will said.
What's the budget for mock turtlenecks for Jason for the budget?
I don't come here under the budget.
I've already maxed it.
It's a fair question.
First of all, you're allowed to mock a mock turtle neck.
It's built into the name.
Name.
Okay.
But by the way, you'll never see me in a mock turtleneck.
You'll never see me in a turtleneck for sure because I've got probably, you know,
they ask you sometimes, you know, what's the one thing you change about your body?
It's probably my non-superhero jawline.
I've got sort of like a
sort of a diagonal
a diagonal from the end of my chin
to my Adam's apple as opposed to a 90 degree thing
so if I wear a turtleneck
I then have the turkey goblet
hangover over the edge
that cascades, that skin
that cascades over the edge of the turtle
I can't have it
I disagree you both have nice
silhouettes
go back to the thing though
about being cold it's cold in L.A
I came down the stairs today I'm not
not making this up I came downstairs
And Scotty had the heat on, on the first floor of Los Angeles,
and the heat.
And I was sweating by the time I got to the bottom of it.
Sean, you come down the stairs, your Hollywood house.
Every day like Gloria Swanson, right?
That's right.
In a flowing house coat.
Yeah.
Ready for my close-up.
It's so great to see you guys.
It's so great to see you guys, too.
This is really exciting.
I'm excited for you guys to talk to our guest today.
Oh, I am excited to listen.
Because our guest is somebody, this is a mega talent.
This person is a person who's been doing it for a long time.
This person is not just an actor.
This person is a writer.
This person is a skilled musician who started playing violin at the age of three.
They can play the piano, accordion, trombone, guitar, harmonica,
and has written and improvised music a lot in a show that they've done now for many, many years.
This person received an honorary done.
doctorate from performing arts from Merrimack College.
This person, you know, was active at Williamstown Theater Festival back in the day.
This person has gone onto a huge career in television in, I guess, the longest-running TV
comedy of all time.
This person has to be slow down here.
I want to do some guesses here.
Well, this is my guess, and it makes sense because this is my friend, and I'm so happy
to have my friend, and I want you guys to start trying to guess.
This person has done lots of movies.
This person was in the Lego movie with me.
This is Charlie Day?
The longest running comedy.
The Lego movie, too.
Yeah.
Pacific Rim.
Horrible bosses and its sequel.
Well, it's got to be Chuck Day.
Yeah, it's Chuck Day.
Oh, my God.
All right.
You're scraping the bottom of the barrel,
Matt, boy.
No, I was...
Time to wrap the show up.
So, Chuck,
what about...
This is, now, I think the reason you've taken so long to book on this is your schedule.
It took a real long time for someone to ask me.
I can't believe Rob McElhaney beat you onto this show.
What does that say about us?
Here's my favorite part, is that Bateman and Chuck Day have been friends for many years.
They've done a few movies together, and I was so happy to steal Charlie as my guest from under Bateman.
Just a really point.
I would have had him on, too.
I know.
I think maybe you did ask me.
Yeah, definitely.
And then you were saying, yeah, gosh, you know, I don't know.
We're starting a podcast.
And I think he gave me a little bit of a runaround.
And I don't like to pressure people.
I know you were looking to get paid quite a bit of money for today's spot.
I was waiting for you guys to make money so I could start make money, which is cool.
Because Will cut me a great check for this.
I had to send him over cash, a guy with a rucksack full of cash.
Yeah.
And that's a pay cut for me, guys.
Because you're not doing that well, right?
You know, that show is not paying you.
I've made a lot of bad decisions, though.
You know what I mean?
I made a lot of sketchy calls.
Wait, we had, Charlie, we had McElhaney on it.
And is it really the longest running sitcom in history?
Yeah.
Yeah, well, years.
If you don't count episodes, I think you did more episodes of Will and Grace in like two seasons.
And then we've done, but.
How many years is it now?
This is something we don't want to gloss over because this is, this is, you should be,
and I'm sure you are, so proud of how long this show has been on the air.
Yeah, it's so cool.
This doesn't just make itself.
We're talking, of course, about all of a sudden in Philadelphia.
I had 15 years.
Jesus.
We just have a 15th season.
15 years.
And you're about to do another one or two?
I don't know, at least another one.
And we'll see after that.
Look at the way he's positioning right there.
I know.
He knows Fox is listening.
Of course.
Or whatever the hell it is.
And he's going to jam him again.
He's going to get it to 20.
You know what it is.
We've done a lot.
We've done a lot of these.
I don't know how long we can keep them off.
Nothing adds more zeros than a foot out the door, right?
I mean, that's just gets them.
That's true, yeah.
So, Charlie, let's talk a little bit about it,
because we're talking about all of a Sunday in Philadelphia,
which is a huge, long-running show, longest by years.
Could you have imagined, take us back to the day
when you actually, when it actually became a TV show?
Because we had Rob on here when we talked about it.
You guys made some videos and stuff and you shot some stuff.
Am I remembering that correctly, and you took it to FX?
Yeah, that's basically it.
I mean, we were shooting in my apartment,
which was on the corner of Western and Franklin there.
I lived...
And I think I paid $600 a month for rent.
You got Rob.
Quick aside, Jason, last time you were east of Coenga,
five, four, three, three, two,
back in the drug days, for sure.
Yeah, I think I might have seen you scoring on the corner.
There was a pay phone I'd like to hang out out.
Yeah, I'd have to run you down a dime bag or something.
I was still there.
I'm sure what it was.
Oh, my God.
So you're in your apartment.
Right, and was there a phone call from your agent or manager or something that said,
they bought it?
You know what it was?
So we had shot this thing and it was like pretty good, but we knew we'd sort of not hit the nail on the head.
And we had nothing really going on.
So we redid the whole thing.
We were doing it so cheaply.
We were holding the cameras.
We had a little boom.
It was real low rent.
And our second goal,
around was pretty funny. We thought, are there something here? And we were all at three arts
management at the time. So like Nick Frankel and Michael Rotenberg took it to WME, and they kind of sat on it
for a while. They're like, yeah, maybe we'll hook you up with a big producer. And we waited forever for
John Favreau to watch it. And he just, I guess he never got around to it.
The one that got away. I know. Well, I mean, I'm so glad I'm not cutting half a check to
John, you know, like, I mean, I'm sure he would have helped a lot, but, you know, it's nice not to have to be paying him anything.
But eventually, we got kind of bored, and we shot a third episode.
Literally, you shot it because you were just in this waiting because the agencies are so you're just, you guys are on their timetable.
Well, that, and the only thing to do on Western is either move the dime bags or shoot another episode.
And it should be, it should be noted, can I just take this?
Am I right in saying this?
and you guys can agree or disagree with me.
The agenting in show business is hilarious because, like,
you can't get in touch with your agent in the first thing in the morning
because they're in a staff meeting.
Every agent takes lunch at one o'clock no matter what,
so they're out of the office for two hours.
But they need an hour or so to get there, so they leave at 12.
Sorry, we lost him.
He's on his way to a lunch.
And then he's back at three.
Then they do the thing as like, well, he's not in the office.
Why not?
Well, because next week is Thanksgiving.
Yeah, next week is Thanksgiving.
Not this week.
The fuck are you doing it?
And then the month of December.
And then the month of December, sorry, it's the holidays, sure, got it, and then they go.
And then, you know, obviously, Sundance is at the end of January.
So nobody's back till Feb 1.
It's the most ridiculous racket of all time.
We were getting a lot of it.
Yeah.
The end of the day goes like this, well, the end of the day goes, sorry, we're closed.
He's going to start rolling calls, and then they call knowing you're not going to pick up.
Yeah, or they call you at 7 o'clock, and you're having dinner with the kid,
And you're like, why are you calling me now?
Right.
Sorry.
Sorry, Charley.
No, that's it, though.
We lost sort of patience with that kind of thing.
And we said, we're going to leave you guys and we're going to go to a different agency with this.
And that sort of prompted them setting a bunch of meetings.
And Rob went around because we thought maybe it would be too much to have all three of us in the meeting.
So Rob went.
And we had an offer from FX to shoot a, you know, a real pilot with a real budget.
Rob's the closer.
He's a closer.
He's better in the meeting.
he's a better salesman.
Now, how are you in meetings?
Because I don't think I'm great in meetings.
I don't enjoy them.
I feel like I'm trapped in an office.
I feel like I'm 45 minutes from getting out of these walls,
so it better not go bad in the next minute or two because I'm stuck.
Like all those things I start to feel, I start to think about,
and then just the walls start getting closer and closer like Star Wars.
How are you?
Do you look at it as like an arena?
Like, I'm on stage or this is fun, like let's win.
or are you looking to get out of there?
It's tough.
It's a tough part of this business.
You know, it depends.
They're all very different.
You go into a meeting and you just,
sometimes you just get cold stairs.
Yeah.
Well, often.
I do have that vibe sometimes of like,
well, here's the idea, guys.
Do you want to buy it or not?
Okay.
If you have that indifference, what's it called, Will?
It's called sexy.
It's called sexy indifference.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Charlie, you know about his sexy indifference, right?
Yeah.
It's one of it.
I'm still working on it.
The major terms.
But yeah, you know, it's, you're either selling or you're buying.
The buyers usually look at you with absolutely no expression because they can.
The sellers, us, have to go in there like, you know, circus clowns because we're selling.
And that's really what we do in this business.
And in a good year, you're selling, you know, you're selling yourself six, seven, eight times and winning.
Like, in other words, you get fired, you know, half a dozen times.
rehired half a dozen times if you're killing it. So, I mean, how many people in other industries
have to sell themselves or get fired or rehired maybe three, four times over their whole life?
I mean, we've got to do that all the time. It's tough. It was hard for me. It is crazy,
but then you look at the flip of it, Charlie. So you guys, you guys go through this process.
You make this thing, you wait, you make this thing, you wait, you're waiting, you have to
threaten to leave the agency. Finally, FX buys it. You guys are kind of a little bit hat in hand.
And now all these years later, you're at the position we asked you're at, like, are you going to do more?
Maybe I'll do one more, whatever.
Like, you have, the tables have turned a little bit.
Yeah, well.
Not a little bit, a lot.
Yeah, I mean, I think the thing is, though, when we were shooting that pilot, I was 27 years old.
Right.
And I'm 46, and so I feel like, you know, I put in my time with this one.
You look 23, though.
I know it's incredible.
I know. It's incredible.
Yeah. Must be a real stress-free set there.
But we all make stuff
we all produce or write or direct or act whatever
And Charlie kind of what Jason was talking about
Is there a point where you
Like are you getting to a point
Where it's bothersome that the grind is getting to you
About getting all these nose?
Because it seems now to put together a package
To sell something you have to really stack the deck high
Before anybody will even consider
You hear about Merrill Streep getting past or on
Or whoever these big stars
Go out to pitch these shows
and they get past, well, if they get past
and I'm stacking these deck and we're getting
those, what does it take to keep a production
company going? I like to
get everything done independently
of a partner. So, you know,
like, I'd rather, if I'm
going to be pitching a movie, I'd rather have the whole thing
written. Right. And say, you know,
and a director in place, and an actor
in place. Yeah. Yeah. We're going.
This is what it is. So all they do is write the check.
Basically. Yeah. Yeah.
You know, as it should be.
Yeah, but then that means you got to do a bunch of work for
free ahead of time, which is cool if you've got the time and the funds to bank on yourself
and work for free for a little while.
Look, at some point, you're going to have to do that work anyway.
So I'm usually, it depends, right?
There's other things I'll pitch and I'll know, okay, I want to get a writer on this
and I want to get that person paid.
But even then, I'll work with that writer.
I'll develop a whole outline.
So that movie is basically ready to go.
and I'll attach a few people to the movie
and then I'll go and it be like,
here it is, this is what it is,
here's who's acting in it, here's the director,
now please pay this guy right.
And Will and Sean, you've got to understand.
This guy is, he's so fast and he's so good.
He wrote horrible bosses too
on a five-hour plane ride from New York to Los Angeles.
I'm not exaggerating.
He did a complete rewrite, page one rewrite on it,
and we used most of it.
Wow.
Out of deference to our writers that wrote the draft
before. I'm exaggerating a little bit, but Charlie deserves a great deal of credit for that.
Well, I appreciate that. I don't want to take credit away from, you know, the guys who wound
up doing them.
You don't even remember the names. He's fast, but he is a critic. I'm fast with writing. I'm
real slow with names. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
Wait, so speaking of names, so you and obviously you have a long-time relationship with
Rob McLean.
How did you guys first meet?
What was that?
I met Rob on a plane.
So we were both being flown out.
We were both being flown out to test for a pilot for the same role.
And it was one of those things where, you know, you're in the airport and you're like,
oh, this guy's got to be an actor.
You know, he's got that look.
And the show is called Matherhouse.
It was about college kids or something like that.
And, you know, I think, I don't know when I said hello, but maybe after the plane landed.
Where were you coming from?
From New York?
From New York, yeah.
We both lived in New York and we were flying out.
You know, they put you up on, like the Hilton or something right off the 101 there.
Oh, yeah.
By Universal.
No way.
Many times.
So we're both staying there and then.
You used to find Jason on the sign.
Yeah.
I used to remember pilot season I used to come out there and stay there or the Sheraton or the Intercontinental over by Fox,
which is where Tony Hale and I stayed for the arrested test.
Anyway, keep going.
It was my second time that happened.
It happened to me.
I tested for something called weird.
And they liked me for Weird Henry.
And they flew me out.
And then they did one sort of, you know,
round of notes with the producers.
And then the studio was like, this show's not going to work.
And they can't the whole thing.
And then the same thing happened with Rob.
Rob and I both went and tested.
And I remember thinking like, ah, I got this guy.
He doesn't have the charisma.
I'm not worried about him.
Look at his stupid face.
Look at his dumb face, man.
He's never going to make it in show business.
He'll never own a football team with
Ryan Reynolds.
Yeah.
Forget it.
He was too handsome.
I was like, he's too modely.
You know,
you need someone real.
And then the same thing happened.
They canned the whole show
while we were out there.
And we just kind of bonded
and stayed buddies and, you know,
now I can't get rid of him.
You know, every year I'm like,
well, maybe we've done it with the show.
He's like, come on, one more.
Let's go.
And then, so not only can you not get rid of them
always sunny,
then you guys create Mythic Quest
with,
it wasn't just the two of you with somebody else too.
Yeah, with Megan Gans.
Megan Gantz. Yes, of course.
Yeah, no, I can't get rid of this guy.
You know, I go on podcasts. I'm just talking about him.
I'm like, I hear him. He barely talks about me.
I'm talking about this guy constantly.
No, no, he talks about you quite a bit. We just can't repeat it.
Oh, okay.
And you guys started a podcast together too. Now you've got this all with sunny podcasts.
And now we're talking about the show and people are listening.
But we're not here to plug that. We're not going to talk about that.
No, let's plug all everything you got.
Okay.
I think we should really, if we really want to get this cooking, we should just talk about golf.
Let's go.
First of all, when we were doing horrible bosses, and I'm a bit of a golf nut, I would say, oh,
Jason, you know, I heard you used to golf and you said, yeah, I don't do it anymore.
I was like, well, you should come out with me, you know, maybe some time and just, you know,
dust off the old sticks and hit a few.
You are the most golfing man I know now.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
Non-stop.
And back then, back then I was very disciplined.
I didn't want to dance with the dragon again.
You know, I've got addiction issues.
Yes, yes, yes.
You are fully addicted to golf.
Yeah.
Dance with the drag.
Yeah, no, no, that's the saying.
And then during COVID, you know, Will just threw me a lifeline.
He said, listen, buddy, you got to step away from Rachel Maddow, take your PJs off,
and let's get out there, do something socially distant.
Let's play golf.
And two weeks later, we were in Pebble Beach.
Yeah.
No joke.
He put it right in my arm.
I love it.
Well, I love that you do it.
I hope you don't give it up.
No, no, I don't. Look at me. I'm dressed. Look at my outfit, for Christ's sake. I'm a half hour from the tea.
We'll keep it snappy because I know you got a tea time. Yeah, let's go. Charlie, I have a...
Sean, I know your question is going to be, hey, Charlie, how long and straight are you off the tea?
Very, he's very consistent off the tea. It's unbelievable.
This guy's a single-digit handicap listeners. Anybody who's into golf, this guy, this guy doesn't shoot over 80.
It's gross. He's a natural athlete. He played a lot of baseball when he was coming up.
the most you know about me.
This is surprising.
Wait, so Charlie,
speaking of growing up,
so I mentioned in the thing
that you play piano
and you play all these instruments,
what's up with that?
I don't know where the...
Look at Sean perk up.
Sean doesn't want to talk about
a long off the tea,
but, oh, let's get that harmonica in his mouth, huh?
Let's do it.
I probably have one lying around.
I don't know where the violin thing came.
Like, I was...
Thank you.
You have that ready to go?
Yeah, anytime there's a bad joke.
Hey, where's that keyboard we were going to introduce this year, Sean?
Yeah.
I know, I'm too lazy to lift this up and go in there because they've got to hook it all up.
But wait, Charlie, do you still...
Do you still play violin?
Do you still play these instruments?
No, I never played the violin.
That's one of those.
So that was not true.
No, I think I played the violin from like three to three in one month.
You know, where my parents were like, well, this is too young.
Wikipedia is very accurate.
Is there an instrument that you excel at or that you've done?
stick with?
Keep it clean.
I don't excel at any of them.
But I can play a little piano and a little guitar.
I can write like a goofy song that we put on Sunny.
But was that something that your parents, like,
encouraged, like, did you take piano lessons and guitar lessons?
Yes.
I took piano lessons maybe until I was 10,
and then I switched to the trombone.
I used to have a little sweatshirt because I was in the school band
that said Charlie trombone.
So that became my nickname for too long.
You know the problem with the trombone is if you leave it in the rain.
It gets rusty.
You know what right.
It's true.
It's true if you leave it in the rain.
Clean it's clean.
Well, you keep it clean.
You get some kind of brass cleaner or something like that.
Charlie, when you write and produce or director,
whatever you do, do you think about music when you're doing it or is it an afterthought?
It's a big part of how I write something.
I'll be just listening to, you know, a style of music and I'll have an idea.
The Pesh mode.
Yeah, I'll be listening to Depeche Mode.
I'll be thinking, I've got to do a movie with Bateman where he, you know,
You know, where's eye shadow and trench coats?
Yeah.
You should see me.
I got great got great got got skills.
Yeah.
I do love Depeche Mode.
Wait, Charlie, I know so little about, so it says that you were born in New York, in the city.
Yeah.
True story?
True story.
Because my parents, my parents both met at Columbia, where they were both music, getting their doctorate's in musicology.
Wait a second.
Pump the brakes.
Wow.
So your parents, so you kind of brush through the whole music thing
and your own involvement with me.
Your parents have degrees in music from Columbia?
Yeah.
My parents are very smart.
Smart, as is my sister.
She also has her PhD in musicology.
What happened?
What happened here was that, you know, I'm an idiot.
And I was like, I got to get away from this music thing.
So, you know, I'm taking trombone lessons
and all my buddies are outside playing baseball.
And I eventually, you know, walk.
walked away from it all and gave it up.
But then when I got to like maybe a senior in high school or college,
I picked up the guitar and I was like,
oh, this is maybe could be cool or a way to meet a girl.
And then I got back into it.
But I didn't want to be, they had no money.
And I didn't want to be a music person.
So they became an actor.
So they're at Columbia.
They're both taking, they're both in programs, music programs at Columbia.
They meet, you're born in the city.
And then what happens?
How long did you live there?
Not long.
And then my dad got a job at a college in Rhode Island.
And my mother's family was from Rhode Island way back, way back.
And they went and never left.
They're still there.
So you grew up in Rhode Island.
I grew up in Rhode Island, yeah.
Yeah.
How did the acting thing hit you?
Was it like a high school drama thing?
That's a good question.
I mean, I did plays like in third and fourth grade
and always enjoyed it.
And then I wanted to do the school plays in high school,
but I was kind of too nervous to join the group.
I thought, ah, I don't, I don't know.
But with the musical background,
what do you think that you can combine the plays and the music
and do what, Sean, what do we call that?
The theater that's got...
There's a music-based theater out there.
I'm not quite sure.
I don't think there's a term for it yet.
What would be an example of something that you might do on musical theater?
Five, six, seven, eight.
You know, ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
You guys are going to have.
I'd like to take that slide whistle away from them.
I mean.
So then Charlie, so then you finish high school and you say,
I'm going to go to New York City
and I'm going to try to become a professional guitar player or actor.
Yes, I did have that thought.
I was like, well, do it?
Which one?
I didn't know.
I was like, maybe I want to write music or maybe I want to do acting.
But you knew your future wasn't in Rhode Island.
It was probably in Manhattan.
Yeah.
Well, first I went to college, Jason.
Where was that?
Wait, hang on.
What's college?
Yeah, it's a school after the studio school.
Voluntary additional school?
I don't understand it.
Voluntary.
Yeah, that's the part I couldn't compute when I was.
What trailer was that in on the Warner Lot?
Yeah, one with a flat tire.
Here's what happened.
I went to the voluntary additional school,
and they had a theater program,
but they also had a baseball team.
And I didn't make the baseball team,
and I thought, well, I'll go join the theater club.
And then I just got hooked.
I was like doing the plays, and it seems to...
Was this school?
in New York? This school was
in northern Massachusetts called Merrimack
College and you could
get in if you had a pulse and
they let me in and
my favorite thing in the world is
swapping horrible
theater stories. Did I tell you guys about the
wheelchair story?
You got to go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's just pull the interview over to the side.
Hang on.
No, really quick.
This was a horror. I was a
sophomore in high school and
And I was in charge of changing the scenery, right?
The batons that would lift the scenery.
So in between we had like, we were doing one act.
So in between each act, we had like, you know, 15, 30 seconds to change the big, huge scenery
and pull them up.
And I was in charge of all those hydraulics.
So the stage manager points to me, she's like, go.
And I didn't realize there was a rope hanging on the side that somehow hooked onto the wheelchair
that the guy needed in the next scene.
This is an episode from a cartoon I saw.
No, I swear to God, this happened.
And I raised it.
and the hook pulled the wheelchair up.
So the curtain goes up
and the wheelchair is just swinging, hanging in midair.
And the guy's first line was, you know,
something like, I don't know if I'll ever walk again.
But he had to, it was awful.
Oh, golly.
Back to SmartList.
Hey, Charlie.
So you're up there, so you come down out of the junior college
and you come to New York City
and you don't just knock.
on a door and say I'm here, I'd like to be an actor.
Do you look in the paper for auditions or an agent or what was your first step?
Yeah, I did all that crap.
You know, you get the village voice and you're looking through all those things.
I had a really lucky break when I was in college.
There was a guy there named John Fusman and he was like one of those guys who was like 35 and in college.
And just hanging out just outside the school grounds.
Basically.
Yeah.
Yeah, and he had tipped me off to a place called the Williamstown Theater Festival.
Sure. And I went there to sort of, you know, empty garbage cans and maybe say one line in a play and just intern.
And they had like a program where you could audition and be part of a non-equity group.
And after my first summer there, I was still in college.
The next year I auditioned and I got to be part of that group.
A bunch of agents go up there, you're right?
Yeah, yeah.
After my third year there, I got an agent.
Sean, did you ever do that?
I'd love to do Williamstown.
Did you ever do that?
I would love to, no, but I would love to.
But, you know, Charlie was going to ask you,
like, there's, when we were all young, all four of us
and other people like us that are actors,
there was a definite path to what you wanted, right?
You got your head shots,
and then you had your resume on the back,
and then you would submit them to agents,
and then agents was in,
but now it seems so different.
Do you have friends, like,
Does your sister have friends?
I'm like, hey, Charlie, can you help my friend out?
They want to get into the biz and they need advice.
I mean, do you ever get people coming to you?
And what would that advice be now for kids rather than when we were growing up?
Weirdly, I don't get too much of that.
I don't know if I don't give off a vibe of that I'll help or I'm not sure why.
Do you feel, no, but let me rephrase that.
Do you feel shitty about yourself that nobody wants acting tips from you?
or career advice
I had that Sean you know when I was a kid
this true story when I was living in New York
and I was my I didn't know anybody in New York
and somehow my mom knew
through somebody from like Winnipeg
knew the actor Len Carey. Do you know that guy
sure Len Cario
and so somehow she's like you should call him
and I was like okay so I called them
poor guy because now I sort of
30 years later I get that flip,
which is like, he's like,
hey, what can I do for you?
I'm like, well, I'm just in New York
and I'm going to theater school.
I'm like, okay.
I'm ready to be successful.
Yeah, and like I get now that position.
I even felt it at the time where he's like,
I don't know what you want me to do for you, buddy,
but, you know, I'm worried about my own day to day over here.
Right, right.
And so you do get those calls sometimes from friends of friends,
and they go, hey, our kid is 18,
and he's moving to New York,
and can you call him and give him some advice?
And there's really nothing you can say to anybody.
I actually like it.
I actually don't mind it.
Yeah, it's all about timing, but yeah, I actually, actually like...
What do you tell people, you know,
because getting an agent, like you do have to get into kind of a showcase situation.
It's just really tough for everybody.
I think you have to create your own path.
You know, gone are the days of relying and waiting on phone calls and agents and all that to do it for you.
You have to pick up a camera.
You have to write the thing, direct the thing, act the thing, put it on YouTube,
all that kind of stuff and Instagram.
And that's how,
because every Instagram star wants to be an actor
and every actor wants to be, like, have the most followers.
Well, Charlie, you guys were kind of like the first people
to really do that in a way that has been not just successful,
but also had longevity.
You guys created your own stuff.
That was not the norm before you guys did that.
No, that's true, yeah.
Although, you know, in some ways, doesn't everybody do that?
Like, somebody...
I guess the Lonely Island guys did that, too.
Yeah, like...
Well, but they were already part of an infrastructure there at Saturday Night Live.
No, no, no, no, before.
Those guys made videos and stuff.
When they did, they did.
Andy Samir.
Andy and Akiva and Yoram did.
Oh, really?
Yeah, they made some videos on Lonely Island.
Then they made a pilot called Awesome Town that Phil and Chris, Phil Lord and Chris Miller produced.
Have you ever seen that?
It's really, it's really rad.
But they did the same thing, which was, but again, that was around the same time that Sunny started.
It was back in that.
What was unique about what we did is we did it for television.
Right.
You know, like you, there was a lot of that in independent film.
If you're the Cohen brothers, you know, you raise money, you do Blood Simple,
and then you go do Raising Arizona, whatever it is.
And I guess we just took that model to television.
And we said, well, we'll, you know, we'll do the first one real cheap and down dirty.
And then hopefully someone gives us money to do this more legitimately.
But going back to your question before, I often do promote Williamstown,
which for me was like a showcase situation.
or if you're really serious about acting,
go to grad school, which I'd wish I'd done.
Because that place was not only boot camp for acting,
it was boot camp for you better show up and shine.
Because in that group, in that non-equity group,
it was myself and Catherine Hahn and Sterling Brown.
Wow.
And, I mean, the competition was so fierce.
And Jimmy Simpson, and these people were going to outshine you.
They weren't trying to outshine you,
but they were going to do their work.
and they were going to be, you know,
they were going to come to rehearsal, not set,
and just blow it out of the water.
So you had to learn how to,
I feel like my first summer there,
I did well in some plays,
and I thought the next year I thought everyone would be like,
well, he's the man, let's give him everything,
and it wasn't that way, you know,
it was a rude awakening of like,
well, you did that, what are you going to do now?
So that was such a good boot camp in terms of, like,
do your work, work hard,
make sure you make sure you're not wasting anybody's time.
It's funny you say that I remember having one of my acting teachers years ago
he was saying like, look, all the process you do, all the work you do, whatever,
when you show up on said, they don't give a shit.
You've got to deliver in the moment and that's it.
And that was the only sort of piece of advice that I've ever given young people,
which is just like you've got to be on top of your shit.
You've got to know your shit like you said.
You've got to be ready to deliver in the moment because that's what matters.
Yeah, and it's a bit exhausting, right?
You do, like you put all this work.
into this years go by you you develop whatever fame success and you kind of think okay well now i can
coast but you know the phone doesn't really ring maybe it does for decaprio but for nobody else like
you have to like you got to put something together and you have to and then when you when you are in it
you can't stink right you got to yeah you got to shine um your son is he too young to know that he
wants to do what dad does or yeah where mom does too both you guys are actors yeah yeah mary elizabeth has
this great part in Paul Thomas Anderson's film right now.
Oh, she's great at it.
That movie's amazing.
Yeah, that guy.
Paul Thomas Anderson?
Yeah, talk about a guy.
I think he's going to work out for him, I think.
He's going to make it.
He's a great debut.
He has going to make it.
Paul Thomas Anderson is the greatest director of all time.
And go.
And ignite.
How about he's my favorite, for sure?
I know, me too.
He's the greatest.
I got to go see a screening of that movie at his house,
which, you know,
he has these, maybe he doesn't want, but he has like these film projectors.
He's got like this barn that he's converted into like a screening room.
And for Tracy, the name of the movie is.
Liquorice pizza.
Liquorce pizza.
Yeah.
Which is the name of a record store that was all over the valley when I was growing up.
Right.
It's, uh, anyway.
So he's got this cool.
That's why you're crying.
So, so, and your wife, Emmy, Mary Elizabeth Ellis, whom I know, she and I did a pilot together.
Years ago, as you know.
Yes, yes.
And she's a tremendously talented actor,
and she's in Paul Thomas Anderson's movie Liquorice Pizza.
So you went to a screening at his screening.
At his house.
Screening burn.
Yeah, just to kind of...
And then to get to hang out with Maya Rudolph.
So that was a...
Who's our pal?
I just didn't want to blow it for my wife.
I'm like, just keep cool, man, and don't get drunk and don't act dumb.
Did you stand up with a bunch of notes at the end of it?
I had a couple notes, but he wasn't listening, you know?
That's the problem.
these artists.
Yeah, we were locked.
Pop Charlie Day in for a couple scenes.
That's really going to make this movie pop.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
Now, listen, Charlie, for your new podcast,
which I think it's becoming really popular, isn't it?
Do you guys have guests on,
or is it just you three chatting?
Right now, it's just us chatting.
I mean, that kind of caught us off guard, you know.
This was my gripe with McElhenney.
About two years ago, I was like,
we should do a sunny podcast.
We should just talk about the show,
the fans will probably want to hear that.
And he's like, ah, everybody's doing podcasts, you know, like, you know, we're too late.
Then this year he shows up, he goes, you know what we should do?
A sunny podcast.
Oh, boy.
I'm like, this motherfucker.
I'm like, yeah, I know this guy.
But here's the difference.
And here's why I've benefited so greatly from a partnership with Rob.
When I said it, it was just gobbledygook talk.
And when he said it, he already had the mics and the producer lined up and ready to go.
He's an action.
He's an action guy.
So it's been good for me to.
unite with an action guy.
Being on that side of it, do you,
and we all know this as actors,
promoting and marketing and all that stuff,
having to do talk shows and whatever podcast
or whatever the thing is,
do you have a preference of being a guest or a host?
Well, I guess we're not really hosting anyone,
so I don't know for hosting yet.
Yeah, I mean, you're kind of hosting a podcast, but yeah.
We're really just kind of shooting the shit.
Okay.
People seem to want to listen to it.
But you're, I think that one of the things,
We're all talking about the same thing.
We obviously have, there are a lot of similarities,
which is you talk about we create our own weather,
we do our own thing,
and we do a lot of different things.
You're doing a podcast, you do your show,
you've got this new movie on Amazon,
that was a sexy segue.
That was a good segue, yeah.
So I did a rom-com, finally.
So you did a rom-com, yeah.
Saw me as ROM.
So talk a little bit about,
because I want to get into,
you do do a lot of different stuff
and you've got a lot of different gears.
which is commendable, and you're, you know, you're a talented guy.
So you go and you do a rom-com.
What was the, were you just like, yeah, fuck it, I could do a rom-com.
I was always dying to do a rom-com because I actually really enjoy them.
And I sort of wanted to have my, you know, Tom Hanks moment or Billy Crystal or whatever.
Was there a sex scene?
No, there's, there's, you know.
Is there a kiss?
Hey, cool it.
Hey, take it easy, man.
What are you imagining? Jason, what are you imagining?
Talk to what you're imagining.
Well, because some people can go, they're whole.
whole careers or a large portion of it without ever doing a sex scene.
And then all of a sudden, the day shows up and it's like, oh, my God, I've been in this business
30 years.
And I've never had to like fake lovemaking.
Did you have to do that?
No, that's a good question.
Have you ever had to do that?
Yeah, I have a, I have a very graphic one on It's Always Sunny where we did a ski episode
and we were making sort of fun of like 80s ski movies and over the top sex scenes.
So, you know, I would like that go.
It was fine, you know.
You don't have to ask him in a whisper, Will.
You don't just say, walk us through it.
I mean, you know, it's always the case of me with the sex things.
I'm always, I always feel bad for the other person.
You know, I'm like, hey, look, I'm sorry, it's just me and this, you know, I'm pasty.
Sean, you had to do one?
Yeah, there was this cult show, which is fantastic, called Campus Ladies,
with Carrie Aesley and Kristen Susson and Will Forte was on it,
and a bunch of funny people were on it.
Jonah Hill. That was Jonah Hill's first show.
And I played somebody who wasn't the brightest, who always wore a backpack.
How'd you get into that character?
Wow. So I just put a backpack on.
And then I had to wear no clothes except the backpack and have sex with, and literally have intercourse with Kristen Susson.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
How did that go?
Jason?
Fine.
Oh, sorry, go ahead. Sean. Finish up.
How is it?
That was it?
Jason, what about your sex stuff?
I've got a loose connection. Can you guys hear me okay?
Yeah.
Is that what you said, in the sex scene?
I'm not following.
My wire keeps coming out.
And can you hear me?
Yeah.
And is it in?
I guess that's the big.
Hey, Charlie.
Wait, you didn't answer, Jason, if you've done a sex scene.
I have, and I don't like them.
They're not good.
It's just, you know, all the cliches are true.
You know, you have a, is a very, there's a very difficult line one has to ride,
which is, you know, if you're into it
and you're being passionate convincingly,
things start to move, guys.
And if they don't move,
there's that classic saying,
one of the actors said,
I apologize if I get aroused
and I apologize if I don't get aroused
or something like that.
It's like, it's a, it's a concern.
It's a concern.
Well, Batman, we did this movie called Horrible Bosses.
It was a massive global hit will.
And, um...
Oh, you had a little sex scene with Aniston, right?
That was the first thing...
Yeah, that was the first thing we shot.
Oh, wow, boy.
And that was basically my second time meeting her.
I met her at the, uh, at the read through.
It was like, okay, well, now take all your clothes off
and we'll take these provocative photos.
But I only found it humiliating, you know,
because I was like, oh, man, I should, like go to the gym or like...
Sure.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm really pasty and doughy over here and, uh, you know.
You're probably not used to an image like this in your sexual scenarios.
I had to do a scene in Brother Solomon with Forte
where he comes to, where we make up at the end of the movie,
and I'm in the shower.
And I come out, so I've just got the little sock on
and then nothing else.
And then I got to turn in, he and I have to hug while I'm basically...
No, let's, for Tracy, let's explain what the sock is.
Go ahead, well.
It's basically that.
Like, it's a sock that you put over, it's the thing you put over your junk.
All your meats and cheeses get covered.
Yeah.
It's like it's a little coin purse that's got a couple of pieces of fishing wire on both sides that go around you as a thong.
Okay.
But it's a nude.
It's a nude colored and it's made out of like panty hose and with fishing string on it.
So you can imagine it's just it's not comfortable.
It's not a good looking thing.
And it's difficult at times to fill out.
Will?
And it's well, that was not an issue.
It was more of an issue.
that like it was kind of the, like you said, like,
I'm sorry if I get it aroused,
and I'm sorry if I don't.
And I just thought, boy, this could go either way with Forte.
I have no idea.
Which way did it go?
I don't want to say it, but I just, I love the guy.
Let me just say this, I love the guy.
And you can tell.
Well, you've said plenty.
So Charlie, when, so you're doing this romance and comedy,
you decide you want to do it.
What is the movie?
Well, the movie's called I Want You Back,
and it's with Jenny,
Slate and myself.
She's a talent.
She's pretty good.
Our producing buddy
John Ricard produced this movie.
Another mega talent.
Yeah, and we worked together
on horrible bosses and fist fight.
And I was talking to John,
and I was saying, you know,
we should find something to do.
And he says,
he said, I got these two scripts
and you should look at them.
And he said, but one's a rom-com,
so you probably don't want to do that.
I said, why would I not want to do that?
What a nasty, nasty thing to say.
Nasty thing to say.
And I loved it.
We put it together.
It's a really sweet and funny movie.
By the way, I did have to take my shirt off in it.
And I had this sort of conundrum where the character doesn't work out,
and then he starts working out in the story.
And I thought, well, which body do I go with?
Do I go with the guy who looks like he's not been working out
or the guy that looks like he has been working out?
And I went with the guy who has not been working out.
Yeah, it was...
Did you look at the shooting schedule to sort of plan out
what kind of shape you'd be in?
Because I do that.
I mean, for Tracy, these projects,
they take at least six weeks to shoot,
sometimes 12 or more.
And if you know you got a topless scene on,
as Will likes to call it,
you know, you want to make sure
that you're not having a whole lot of soy sauce
a few days out, you know?
No, I let that go.
I was like, now, that's not what the audience wants for me.
They don't want me to pop that shirt off
and have rippling abs.
They don't want it, they'll be disturbed if they see it.
There's nothing funny about a six-pack.
There's nothing funny about it.
And this is a comedy.
So, Charlie, any recent vacays, as we call it in the biz?
Any vacays with the fam?
I went to Hawaii.
Okay.
I knew that.
I knew that because I saw that pick.
Oh, yeah, you sent us a shot of that beautiful.
You sent that pick in our little chain.
Oh, yeah, I did.
I did.
That's right.
So you went to Hawaii.
Did you go by yourself or did you bring your wife and child?
No, of course I brought my wife and child.
And I played a bunch of golf, and we hung out and relaxed and went to the beach.
And I reset.
It was good.
I was coming right off a bunch of things,
and it was nice to take a break.
Charlie, 2022, what are you most excited about?
Oh, man.
I don't know.
I'm always pretty just excited to be doing this.
I mean, I don't know.
I'm still grateful to be doing it.
Yeah.
I've been polishing up a movie for a good four years
that I directed that Bateman was kind enough to be in.
Yeah, when do we get to see that, Charlie?
Any minute.
I'm right around the corner.
But I was going to sell it.
I was in the process of selling it to a studio.
And I was having some conversations
with a very talented man, Mr. Guillermo del Toro.
And I had a change of heart,
and I took the movie, and I reshot about 20% of it.
Am I still in it?
You're still in it.
You made the cut.
That's been a maddening, long experience,
but I'm really happy with the movie.
So hopefully I'll get it out to the world this year.
I'm excited about that.
I'm excited about this rom-com.
I'm excited about maybe getting some golf in with the boys here, you know?
That's good.
And Horrible Bosses 3, I think we can announce.
Well, now, why didn't we do it, you know?
Well, because...
No one wanted it.
Yeah, because Horrible Buses 2 just basically, you know, cratered.
Did it? Did it shit the bed?
Did it?
By today's standards, it's a huge hit.
Oh, that's true, yeah.
It didn't do as well as the first...
Oh, you mean by pandemic standards?
Yeah, that's right.
By the standards of everybody's staying home and not going to...
going into theaters.
Well, I would like the third one
because I really, really like to collect those sets.
Yeah, oh, yeah.
Things do happen in three.
Maybe we just make it for a price, you know.
But it did turn out people just didn't give shit
about a second one,
so they're really not going to want a third.
It's not really a story that needed a sequel.
Hear me out.
Shornbable Boss is three, but there are two new, Sean, right?
Two new guys who, look, they're kind of...
They just go...
Oh.
They're happening.
My boss is terrible.
My boss is bad.
too. Are you a boss or you're
an employee? Exactly.
But the catchphrase is, my boss is
bad three. Yeah.
Same here. I get it,
Sean. I get it.
So, Charlie, listen, you're
just, you're such a talent.
You're such a good guy. You're a theater.
You're a theater major.
You're a musician, golfer.
Great marriage. Charming little kid.
Your new movie, I want you back.
Your rom-com is out.
I can't wait to see it. And it's on Amazon
now. It's really good. I actually love this movie a lot.
Charlie, I love you. Charlie, thank you for being here.
We see you on the golf course probably in the next few days.
Well, you're teeing off in about, what, 10 minutes?
Yeah, this is already six minutes into my heart out. Yeah, he's got a hard out.
That shows how much he loves you. He never does this if he's got a heart out for golf.
I appreciate the six minutes over. That's good. And you know how persnickety, Jason is about everything.
My range time. I need my range time.
Yeah.
Well, we can come back.
I can come back.
We'll finish this off.
And next time you're on the podcast,
we'll talk about the time when we were coming down 18
and the guy hadn't charged Jason's Tesla.
I had a two-hour drive ahead of me.
It didn't either well.
You made him give him his...
My 20 back.
Yeah, 20 back, yeah, yeah.
I gave him 20 just because I felt bad.
He got yelled at so much.
Jason, you don't know this,
but Charlie and I both tipped the guy
after you took the tip back.
Are you kidding me?
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, we felt bad.
Well, we didn't want to write a story like fucking jigs.
I mean, you were his hero.
He fucked me good.
At least $20.
I should have taken more out of his pocket.
Son of a bitch.
I will say, to your credit, you did preemptively tip the guy and say,
hey, do you mind taking care of this?
He said, great.
And then he didn't do it.
Right.
So it's like, well, I'm going to pay you for the valet parking.
But the extra juice for doing me a solid, which you didn't do.
Yeah.
That then means that you no longer need the money for that.
Let me ask you.
this, if you had shot like even par
that day, like your best round ever.
Do you think you wouldn't have cared?
Do you think you would have been? I would have given him a ride
wherever he wanted to go and all the money in my pocket.
And that is Jason Babeman.
Guys, we'll be right back with an all new episode of Smartless.
He loves his golf.
Charlie,
enjoy the rest of your day.
Great to see your faces, fellas.
Sean, let's hang out some time.
I'm right here just for you.
Not worth it, Charlie.
No?
No. It's got to be better.
Bring the slide whistle.
Next two weeks, Texas, let's get out.
Okay.
I'm busy, but, you know, we'll see.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
He's about to slam a laptop.
He's going to do the good out.
You know, why?
Because, yeah, I'll tell you why I was going to do it,
because Sean Penn did it.
And then I remember, I was listening to that,
I was like, wow, Sean Penn did it.
That's the way to do it.
I think I've done it ever since then.
I was like, well, Sean Penn just slams it down.
Yeah.
That's how you do it.
So I'm going to slam it down.
Bye.
Oh, look, he really did it.
that Charlie Day is
he's a
always a breath of fresh air
isn't it every time you see him
you feel better
He's like we could change his middle name to sunny
Right so just Charlie's sunny day
Yeah always a sunny day
And Charlie
So Sean you don't know Charlie
You've never met him personally
I never met him I did that one voice over
Monsters University with him
But of course you know as you know
When you do animated films
You don't really see the other actor
Because you're doing it a lot
What?
Yeah
So I never really met him
before. But I'm a huge fan.
And I don't know if you've seen Monsters University,
but he steals the movie.
He's hilarious. Yeah, of course. First of all, if you've got,
if you're a fan of comedy or you're a fan of animation
or you've got kids, you've seen Monsters University,
it's a great movie, and he is great in it. And you are,
but he is, but, no, it's a great movie.
And he is such a, I met him the first time was
through his wife, through Emmy, Mary Elizabeth Ellis,
who's such a talent and so cool.
And he's a super nice guy, super real.
And he joked about being down to earth.
He legitimately is.
And then he's incredibly talented.
Yeah, I love him.
And prolific writer and just everything.
And he's so funny.
He's so naturally funny.
You guys got that.
You guys both have very unique voices.
Yes.
Yeah, he's got a very unique voice.
I don't know if I would consider myself too, but he does.
Wait, nobody ever bites my, for my theater stories.
Huh, number one.
So what we save it for a podcast no one wants to listen to?
Okay.
What's funny is that you don't take from that, like, maybe I should stop asking.
I'm telling you, your takeaway is nobody bites on it.
No, I'm telling you, somebody's going to come with a really funny theater story.
I think they're always so funny.
I like that usually your question about funny theater stories ends up with you telling a funny theater story.
I know.
It's just a self-set-up.
Jason, you missed Sean the other day.
Robert and I kept pimping him out
to tell funny stories for everybody at dinner.
Funny theater stories.
So he kept, funny theater stories.
And he kept getting up and telling these hilarious,
they were legitimately hilarious.
And he got so worked up, he had to go to the hospital.
I did.
That's a true story.
So all of a sudden, Jen comes here,
she goes, Sean just went to the hospital.
I'm like, what?
You know, next time I bring up a theater story,
maybe someone will bite,
bite, bite.
Bite.
Oh, bye.
Yes, got it.
Got it.
Not that works, that qualifies.
Love you guys.
Bye.
Love you, bye.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.